endroit si le principe de neutralité
fait obstacle à ce que des agents de
service public ou des salariés du
service public manifestent leurs
croyances religieuses ni la
jurisprudence ni la loi n'étant aux élus
cette interdiction est donc une femme en
france théoriquement dans ledroit a
parfaitement le droit de porter un voile
dans l'espace public
voilà pour le droit maintenant pour la
politique les formations politiques se
prononcent pour une séparation du
religieux et du politique comme le
disait martine aubry ce qu'a prouvé à
l'époque jean luc mélenchon quand vous
êtes élu de la république
vous représentez tout le monde et vous
n'avez pas besoin de montrer un signe
ostentatoire qui relève du domaine privé
bien que chacun vit sa religion comme il
l'entend alors je me tourne vers vous
l'ont lescure donc responsable de la
communication la république en marche
vous êtes d'accord avec les propos de
marc lynch a pas pour vous on doit
porter le voile sur une affiche de
campagne
oui je suis je suis d'accord évidemment
avec cette décision qu'on a annoncé dès
hier soir moi j'ai vécu dix ans canada
au canada il ya des ministres qui
portent des turbans il ya des policières
qui poste qui portent le voile et puis
je suis rentré en france ça me
dérangeait pas là bas mais j'ai bien
découvert que ce sujet était d'abord
extrêmement sensible et que deux il y
avait une montée de l'islam politique
qui visait à représenter des votes
communautaire là où marlène ya bien dit
on est là pour représenter tout le monde
quand on se présente donc moi j'ai rien
contre le voile dans l'espace privé j'ai
rien contre le wild en espace public les
gens s'habillent comme ils veulent j'ai
rien contre acquis pas non plus mais
quand on est dans une affiche politique
dans un tract politique ont fait un acte
politique en s'affichant avec un signe
ostentatoire religieux qu'ils soient à
voile ou ailleurs et je pense qu'en
faisant cet acte politique
vous rentrez le fait religieux dans la
politique et là vous mélanger les genres
et pour moi les gens ils doivent être
séparées alors et hélène qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça parce que vous êtes
sur la fiche moi moi où je vous dire
quand j'ai vu la fiche et je dis je
parlais klocker moi au contraire je me
suis dit je trouvais que la photo était
magnifique
voilà franchement ici mais voilà et
après toute cette polémique et je me
suis dit je suis déçu alors alors pour
nous au départ on est 4 1 sur la fiche
quand vous voyez tous les quatre c'est
un non sujet en fait ça vous n'êtes même
pas posé la question mais on s'est posé
la question mais c'est pas un sujet
parce que sur notre canton
qu'enfin un con con on a représenté
il ya le vivre ensemble déjà qu'ils et
puis on a demandé autour de nous surtout
à des jeunes de moins de 35 ans s'ils
avaient quelque chose de dérangeant
absolument pas je veux vous assurer qu'à
aujourd'hui il y à des personnes autour
de nous en tout cas sur montpellier que
ça ne dérange absolument pas et c'est ça
la représentait pour nous c'est ça la
représentativité de la république c'est
ça vous en faites vous n'êtes pas posé
la question vous êtes bien au contraire
c'est un geste qui va montrer que qui va
être pour le vivre ensemble
bien sûr c'est un geste fort mais où est
ce que vous avez fait la photo aussi on
se dira vous vous êtes même temps
production j'ai dit on fait la photo
parce qu'on est le représentant
on est allé au lac des garrigues son
nombre de cantons où c'est un quartier
populaire même voir des fois et parfois
traité de ghettos le président connaît
bien ce quartier
il est venu plusieurs fois chez nous
pour parer la sécurité notamment
et franchement ça nous a pas posé de
problème mahfoud qu'est ce que c'est
pareil pour vous exactement se présente
sur un compte en très populaire de la
paillade c'est connu la mosson là où il
ya le fameux stade de création de la
boisson de la mosson d'ailleurs effet
partir d'une programme ssa de la mosson
on a mis une affiche et donc nous allons
regarder faire le bon ça vous connaissez
tous qui sait tout ce qui est arrivé
pour les réseaux sociaux et franchement
français était dit franchement
franchement franchement moi
personnellement ça m'a touché vraiment
vraiment ça m'a touché pourquoi parce
que l'affiché à l'image du quartier la
paillasse et une quartier populaire sur
l'avenir de la franchement il faut de
vue il faut venir là bas à la payanne
vous allez voir les jeunes filles comme
ça
sarah elle est ingénieure elle est
ingénieure aléas les militants d'une
associée ça râle va venir nous voir
demain d'ailleurs franck avec nous
demain ça râle et donc l état
aujourd'hui elle est triste mais je
pense que c'était je vous dis je pense
que c'était une fierté pour elle d'être
sur cet axe exactement voilà et que
c'est devenu franchement csa gâcher sa
fête en ce moment exactement ça c'est
vraiment un aboutissement pas parce
qu'elle a voté macron en 2017 à tous on
a moins xiam je suis un marcheur de la
première heure je soutiens ma cran
depuis 2007 j'ai adhéré aux marchands en
avril 2016 et donc
et donc voilà donc on a fait campagne
vers hong kong
montré en 2015 ça on la connaît depuis
depuis longtemps et à la beauté mc ren
pour elle c'est une fierté d'être et
bien sûr je n'avais même pas pensé que
ça allait faire alors c'est ce jour et
voir nos noms et après je vais avoir la
vie de deux jours michel je voudrais
revenir fermer jeudi sur wii isabelle
morini-bosc dit non moi je comprends
tout à fait votre discours et moi la
photo de mon état d'esprit
non non pas du tout mais n'ont pas dit
oui mais si vous dites non c'est quoi
exactement pour les mêmes raisons que
marlène schiappa le dit et d'ailleurs
c'est le voile dans l'espace privé dans
l'espace public ça ne me gêne absolument
pas sur une photo comme ça où l'on lui
sculpture une fois voilà exactement sur
la même ligne sur une photo comme ça ça
me gêne davantage parce que ça peut être
pris comme une provocation
maintenant quand je vous écoute je
comprends parfaitement que vous ne
l'avez pas fait dans ce sens là et que
c'était une photo important oecuméniques
n'avoir absolument rien à voir non mais
non rien à voir ils n'ont pas fait pour
ça que tu sais ça je suis d'accord avec
vous et moi on l'a fait hier soir moi ça
me pose un problème je vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'en fait là vous allez
être élu donc en tant qu'élu vous avez
droit effectivement de porter le voile
il faut savoir quand même une chose
c'est que le personnel et les
fonctionnaires qui vont travailler avec
vous non pas le droit de porter le voile
disent qu'ils ont une obligation de
neutralité
oui mais c'est là où je suis vous êtes
patron d'une entreprise vous croyez moi
les rois vous avez importé en mêlée ça
ça me dérange pas du tout quand
christine boutin députés qu'elle avait
pas en quoi ça te dérange et enfin une
croix mais c'est le mail today reprochés
oui le faire bah oui ça n'aide pas
marteau police a dit ben oui c'est
exactement ce que j'essaie de dire c'est
à dire que quand on fait ça elle l'a
fait si vous n'en aviez pas que oui et
je le regrette tout autant mais elle est
passée de sa vie mieux que nous c'est un
acte politique quand on choisi d'arborer
non je sens qu'à réception pour la
donner sur un tract politique
votre perception à vous venez chercher
un peu d'eau non vous aimez mais je
restais à montpellier j'adore mon colis
the order agents messia juste après gay
au japon qui dit oui les mails tu parle
de provocation en quoi porter le voile
c'est une provocation pour les autres en
quoi c'est gênant dans les jours de
mortes et le voile vécu comme une
provocation sur une affiche départ
l'équipe orale pourquoi en fait sur ses
tenues vestimentaires les passionnés de
pétanque jeux ou bien moelleux
le truc qui me dérange franchement ce
qui est grave et vous avez parlé du
canada il ya un instant
c'est vrai que ce qui est grave c'est
que tout le monde ait remarqué ça et
qu'on ait remarqué ça déjà est vrai il
ya un gros gros problème en tire mais
voilà c'est tout moi cher je vous jure
j'ai vu la fiche je n'ai même pas pensé
on a jugé m mais lyon défections c'est
le contraire on les aime comme système
on n'est pas me semble vraiment gros
sacs sont les seconds canadien oui non
c'est pas comme au canada comme aux
états unis va aux ambassadeurs partie
comme en grande bretagne
ma mort n'est pas noir est un pays laïc
moi effectivement je suis laïc jusqu'au
boutiste mais moi cette affiche ne m'a
pas du tout choqué et je trouve que en
fait la catastrophe dans cette affiche
c'est la république en marche qui a été
le toutou du rassemblement national en
exfiltrant cette femme est en fait
qu'est ce que vous proposez à cette
femme de se taire ne pas être de l epa
quoi elle n'est pas digne de comment
dire de nom de défendre les valeurs on
allait on va laisser monsieur lescure et
[ __ ] mais moi j'ai trouvé à temps mais
je leur réponds la décision qui a été
prise n'exclut en rien cette femme pour
lequel j'ai le plus grand respect vous
l'avez dit c'est tellement respect de la
chasse et la vie publique ont effectué
en effet ce qu'ils n'ont cessons de loi
de porter le droit le voile sur une
affiche oui c'est notre vie c'est le
droit c'est notre droit revient pas la
loi a décidé de ne pas la soutenir
absolument pas ajouté discrimination
mais bien sûr ça serait constitutif
d'une discrimination n'en voulait des
affiches on est sur un affichage
électoral dans lequel il ya le soutien
de la république en marche
donc si vous souhaitez les maintenir
votre affiche on a eu cet échange tout
le week-end avec vous vous avez eu des
échanges avec le référent le verrou qui
vous a dit nous vous demandons de
retirer cette affiche de la remplacer
avec une photo de la même personne sans
voile sur la fiche électorale la sosie
est illégal monsieur ceci constitutive
non discrimination parce que c'est moi
terminer
oui si c'est le termine ici et c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils décident de
maintenir cette photo avec le voile
c'est notre droit de retirer le soutien
de la république en marche et de
l'ensemble de la majorité présidentielle
en passant à cette liste c'est tout
un policier saison faisons c'est un
choix politique qu'ils font moi je suis
extrêmement sensible aux risques
communautaire que j'ai vu dans d'autres
pays dans lequel j'ai vécu je considère
effectivement quand il se présente à une
élection on représente tout le monde
chacun d'entre nous ce n'est pas la
palette de couleurs qui se présente
c'est mon agent spécial et on a le droit
d'en mettre d'accord avec ça en fait
j'ai envie de manger en mai dernier on
ne soutient pas cette liste et c'est le
droit qu'on prend il la tient
exclusivement sur le méphisto mahdia le
politique ne prit pas sur le droit vous
devriez quand même savoir monsieur déjà
la première question mais vous l'avez
poser s'il est de savoir comment sarah
ses portes parce que je suis d'accord
mars que vous sous-estimé le coût
psychologique de ces polémiques je pense
qu'elle a vécu est déçu mais compte tenu
de sa vie en particulier très déçu
alors s'il vous plaît avant d'être venu
dévoiler plus d'offres sera en
particulier tenu des femmes et une jeune
femme de confession musulmane que dit la
loi très clairement
donc on à l'article par exemple 10 de la
déclaration des droits d et la ddhc qui
dispose que nul ne doit être inquiété en
raison de ses opinions qu'elles soient
politiques ou religieuses ensuite on à
l'article 9 de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme qui rappellent que
la liberté de conscience et qu'elle peut
elle peut être exprimé de manière
publique ou privée de manière collective
ou individuelle donc finalement votre
position contraire contrevient
clairement aux droits et à la phase
aller sur le terrain juridique vous
allez sur le terrain
d'ailleurs j'aimerais qu'on ait la vie
de jean beitia pour vous leur
rassemblement
la république en marche à à bien ces
deux mois lorsque l'arrière de la
république en marche elle est bien
emmerdé par ce qui arrive parce que
c'est vrai que au sommet au sommet du
parti au gouvernement on se rend bien
compte que la france est quand même en
proie à une violence
islamique euna lee et de l'autre côté
vous avez en vous avez donc le parti qui
a recyclé un certain nombre de
socialistes qui ont été pendant des
années
oui mais comme hp ont été des années
d'immigration c'est pas ça c'est que il
aussi est ce qu'on peut avant de finir
j'ai pas fait j'ai pas parlé depuis le
début je vous ai laissées par les
falaises donc moi je crois que c'est
très gênant parce que indépendamment si
vous voulez des éléments juridiques
il y a en france quelque chose qui
s'appelle la discrétion religieuses on
parlera de pas comme ça après sa
religion non va scanner mais c'est un
fait une agression c'est une agression
j'ai beaucoup et je le dis j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour le pour le monde
arabo-musulman sauf que c'est pas la
france nous d'accord donc si
effectivement certains se sentent gênés
mais pas là de vivre de vivre leur
religion et leur culture en france parce
que la france a une autre identité
commune ils sont libres d'aller vivre
cette identité ailleurs j'ajoute que
c'est que cette dame pour qui j'ai le
plus grand respect à effet effectivement
elle et elle et elle préside une
association je crois qu'elle a fondée
qui s'appelle tabassum qui est une
fondation qui est très proche des frères
musulmans avant donc effectivement c'est
net c'est une femme c'est une femme et
sa famille et c'est que c'est une
islamiste et je considère que le voile
c'est un étendard du fascisme islamique
c'est une svastika au féminin donc je
n'en veux pas en france point final
voilà en fait alors dernière dernière
chose vous vous qui y est alors je vous
avais dit que effectivement cette phase
est cette dame et ressemble au quartier
mais la france manon ressemblent vous
avez dit line et non la sélection
régionale donc cessé malgré nous elle
ressemble participe à neige
il ya un truc que je pige pas parce que
d'habitude quand on dit le remplacement
vous êtes les premiers à pousser des
cris d'orfraie en dix ans le pas le
remplacement c'est un concept des scans
droite alors si elle ressemble au
quartier on doit sous-entendre que la le
quartier majoritairement habité par les
flammes
donc s'ils voulaient j'avais ça j'aurais
s'aggravant demande quand je vous
demande d'arrêter de parler la poudre 3
millions déjà donc je vais vous dire ce
que disent et hélène ça n'a rien à voir
vous dites vous vous transformez tout
c'est insupportable elle parlait de la
fiche elle dit voilà mine de rien il n'y
est pas allée des quatre personnes qui
représente le quartier qui représente là
et vous non non non il ya le micro cause
mi6 qui trouvent que l'affiché très
belle etc
mais il ya un croco une majorité procès
qui je pense que vous confondez la jsk
en galice et monsieur comme un radical
d'extrême droite ou à ni islamistes
pourraient adhérer à ce qu'on a mis en
haut à gauche de la fiche je crois que
tout le monde sait lire différents mini
pour oui c'est même penser que ces
personnes à la manière des surenchères
nomme la différence doit rester des
françaises moi je ne pense pas dans le
monde évolue vous savez moi non mais moi
je suis né de georges frêche qui était
la liste pour des questions à poser
je ne veux pas que la france évolue dans
ce sens là je me sens a réuni d'anciens
sujet non si c'est pas la france
elle est née l'année l'aide pourquoi
elle n'est pas là aujourd'hui parce que
sarah tout simplement elle n'a pas à
être un porte étendard de ce qu'on ne
veut pas montrer à travers cette affiche
exactement contre ce que vous dites
monsieur ce n'est pas possible c'est une
jeune femme qui est intégrée dans ma
société manifesteront pas puisque
l'indicé
maintenant vous êtes
intégré à quoi monsieur lescure c'est ça
c'est pas l'identité française
moi je n'ai jamais jamais moi je pense
négation jamais ça s'assume ordaz blanc
vous parle de tout ce que monsieur
messier dérives et délire on est dans un
fantasme contre lequel on se bat à
garder là alors vous mais j'insiste et
je préférais que cette polémique n'est
pas lieu il ya eu des échanges entre
vous et les référents tout le week-end
pour vous dire vous retirer ce matériel
électoral vous garder notre soutien on
aurait pu le faire en s'expliquant sur
des règles qui existent depuis 18 mois
dans notre mouvement parce qu'on a eu ce
débat au moment des municipales et on a
dit les gens s'habillent comme ils
veulent mais sur les affiches
électorales
désolé on n'affiche aucun signe
ostentatoire religieux bien vous en
disant mais on dit heureusement vous
avez souhaité et c'est votre droit tig
en dentelle maintenir cette affiche
c'est notre droit de supprimer le
soutien de la majorité présidentielle je
le regrette j'aurais préféré que ça se
fasse en famille ouais en évitant ce
genre de délire c'est maintenant alors
elle heureusement on est là c'est le
sondage est passé alors c'est l'épicerie
verdez sauf que monsieur lescure excusez
moi mais en prenant ses décisions en
foulant vers les terres de l'extrême
droite vous laisser monsieur messia
pouvoir dire cette jeune femme sarah kay
lumineuse avec son voile regarder
comment la leyre orly ont regardé
comment aller regarder
le pan du voile est légal monsieur
médiation comme tu le fais tu attendais
le fait qu'elle soit souriant ce soit
diplômé
ça n'est pas un gage d'intégration à la
france je vous rappelle quand même que
mohammed atta pour prendre cet exemple
un peu exagéré mais qui paie nommé chez
n'a pas géré moi mais d'attaqués tel un
doute l'un des auteurs de l'attentât du
11-septembre était ingénieur dit je mets
sia évidemment c'est horrible et
condamnables comme à chaque fois avec
vous vous allez les excès épouvantail
que d'habitude le porte parole de
republic on m'a dit là je suis pas
d'accord du tout moi je suis pour le
voile de cette dame et c'est l'arrêt
mais hors la loi dans cette dans cette
histoire s'il attend la loi et c'est la
discrimination suis désolé de vous le
dire ou alors fait une nouvelle loi mais
là vous êtes hors la loi non ces
principes de laïcité ne s'applique plus
aux candidats mais pas la retirer des
cultures est candidat retirer ou de
succès notre droit aussi donc à monsieur
lescure juste quand govou quand est ce
que vous avez appris cette affaire est
ce que le président de la république a
été mis au courant
comment vous est pris non mais qui a
pris la décision alors donc on apprend
ça dimanche
alertés par un député de montpellier
doit faire monter ce matériel électoral
donc on décide de prendre contact donc
le référent de l'hérault le gars qui
représente la direction leur marche en
héros vous contacte je pense qu'il ya eu
deux ou trois appels entre dimanche et
lundi pour lequel on vous propose de
retirer ce matin électorale pour faire
un avec la même liste mais sans signe
ostentatoire religieux
vous refusez je le répète c'est leur
droit on leur dit philippe refusé nous
retirons notre soutien il ya une lettre
formelle qui vous a été envoyé à soit
ensuite enlevé le bureau exécutif hier
d'accord instances de gouvernance est
certain que ce que vous sachiez ça c'est
oui c'est ce qui se passait et non pas
au sein de la république en marche alors
que stanislas guérini commence le bureau
exécutif en informant donc c'est le
moment où moi je les ai appris le bureau
exécutif qui à cette polémique
et il rappelle la reine qui a été dit
il ya 18 mois à l'occasion des
municipales on s'habille comme on veut
mais on s'affiche pas sur les traces que
la loi interdit le port du voile sur les
affiches non non non non non c'est notre
droit
bah oui écoutez vous êtes journaliste
oui votre droit de porter le voile
y compris sur la visiblement non parce
que j'ai été victime de menaces de moi
juste terminée on démarre médias médias
décident de vous mettre à l'antenne
c'est un choix éditorial de ce média en
question si un parti décide de mettre
une candidate sur une affiche
c'est un choix politique c'est ce choix
politique nous ne souhaitons pas le
faire sans aucun aucun aucune volonté de
style magnifique soirée la décision pour
une décision comme ça sent le président
vous saurez dans tout en étant décision
du mouvement reste à nice l'as guérini
donc évoque le sujet rappelle la règle
depuis 18 mois
propos cette règle soit ils changent
leur tract soit on leur retire la le
soutien du mouvement tout le monde dit
ok après il s'avère que bardella fait un
tweet
j'ordonne bardella rassemblement d'achat
les lotos du gras si tu dis là moi je
vous dis avant que plutôt que de
retweeter bardella ce qu'on a fait un
peu dans l'urgence on aurait dû prendre
notre couloir et communiqué et là je me
retenais voilà répondra bardella c'est
plus une erreur on est à peu près les
seuls à le faire aujourd'hui on vous
sent très tourné quand même à la maison
puis en tournée quand même vous savez
que la technique en âge vous savez que
la france refuse de plus en plus l'ailé
les expressions d'irrédentisme alter
identitaire dont le communautarisme
islamique que vous venez vous considérez
vous considérez et vous considérait
effectivement que vous avez à y gagner
une sorte de moule à gâteau des tic
boulaga politique
voulait effectivement aller dans le sens
du vent parce que effectivement le vent
est en train de tourner et vous avez
bien raison mais non ou alors il n'était
pas content si je réponds oui à
l'habitude voilà donc en fait moi moi en
tant que marcheur de la première heure
oui c'est ce que vous avez dit cette
déçu je suis déçu de la décision d'arrêt
même parce que c'est franchement c'est
pas l'avoir moi je respecte la loi
je n'aurais jaurès la loi et on puisse
elle même pas non règlement intérieur
moi je suis animateur local je suis anna
marcheurs de la première avec mac rend
justice à la prison juste yen toujours
aux prises quelles que soient dition de
la reine vous aviez je sois édition de
l'art amérindien et il franchement je
suis peiné de cette décision parce que
franchement on a on a un quart
montpellier n'a le cas avant plus du
maire de montpellier mais hautement
publique et qui n'a pas voulu venir vous
voir ici cyril aussi à lies dernière il
a fait la même chose et la recette et il
a révisé une aura eu son adjoint par par
skype mais c'est tout voilà
non en fait je suis il a refusé l'année
dernière la même chose dont nous avons
des poules je le regrette aussi nous
respectons la loi et opus il s'en vante
de ne pas respecter la loi
alors que nous on nous demande dans nos
quartiers mois surprise dans un club de
foot à la paillade et on demande à nos
gamins de respecter la loi
attention mettez le cas c'est donc on
peut bien arrêter on verra lorsque yves
on vous dit rien frédéric politique cela
ne nous a dit monsieur lescure s'est pas
qu'ils n'ont pas respecté la loi ils ont
dit vous pouvez le faire vous pouvez
continuer à mettre cette affiche
vous pouvez vous présenter mais vous
nous avez 200 la république voilà c'est
un choix quand même qui a été motivée
par des positions qui sont quand même
proche du racisme n'induit désolé
aujourd'hui on a une extrême droite qui
dicte les choix politiques et les règles
en magie un peu de bon sens alors on met
une république en marche est prise en
étau entre d'une part l'extrême droite
un à des fins électorales et d'autre
part l'extrême gauche à qui elle fera
appel pour faire barrage au second crise
la mission g la réalité ni quand ma
vision est de croiser les murs et
l'islam
l'extrême la république est laïque lune
s'il vous plaît vraiment et ce qu'on
cherche
il ya déjà des gens qui réagissent
actuellement aux laïcs et qui dit vous
l'excluons raison de son orientation
religieuse
c'est une discrimination non mais si
c'était le cas ça le serait mais c'était
pas le cas on n'exclut personne juste
que ça ne veut rester membre de la
république d'ailleurs je veux pas
personnaliser les trucks que je suis
d'accord avec vous sa première victime
de cette polémique c'est la reine mère
exactement et j'aurais préféré qu'on ait
glissé entre nous au téléphone comme on
a prévu de le faire
vous avez choisi c'est un choix c'est le
vôtre
2 d'une certaine manière lancé cette
polémique je le regarde on ne pouvait
pas de cours elle n'est pas l'effacer le
retrait de la cij en hommage à ces
deux-là delà de l'affichage mais
l'affiché je ne veux pas l'effacer de
l'affiché la dernière a raison mais en
gros si c'est vous qui avez répondu à
jordan bardella c'est ça qui a fait que
nantes est rien c'est très clair on a
pris la décision
on allait communiquer parce
qu'effectivement ça prenait de l'écho
médiatique sur les réseaux sociaux du
fait d'un tweet de jordan bardella
techniquement on n'aurait pas dû le
retweeter bien sûr les biens communiqué
parce que sinon alors là la république
en marche
absente tout vous avez vous avez l'air
de parler de jordan bardella du
rassemblement national comme s'ils
parlaient en or l'ombre en leur nom
propre ces gens représentent quand même
des quelques quelque chose véritable
opposition
j'ai une question à vous poser pourquoi
si le rassemblement national est si
exceptionnel j'écoute mais c'est raté
non mais moi je n'attendais pas mais il
ya des choses que je défende mans il ya
des choses que je défends il ya des
choses que je dépense et d'autres que je
ne défends pas tous pour sète où
l'absence de kottaras que ce soit par
exemple je la défends pas pourquoi les
prévenus voilà les absents ont eu tort
c'est marine le pen qui longe la seriat
jeu je crois qu'ils font en fait c'est
pour cela je vous dis bah c'est interdit
de venir basse est une erreur qui ce
coup là je vous dise voilà donc que je
me sers vous le disiez l'âge donc je ne
je ne je ne cautionne pas tout je vous
retweetez mais par contre quand quelque
chose est vraie vous savez moi encore
une fois je pense que la plus la
totalité des français adorent le monde
arabe et adore la civilisation musulmane
mais dont je suis là mais c'est tout le
monde ne sait pas ici sauf que c'est pas
ici libé amène on attendait quand vous
vous prouver qu'elle est à l'école de la
république se voit pas et qui sait vous
je vais vous les universités je vais
vous le dire en un mot comme en mille
oui je les aimais tard en droit on a
mûri ça n'a rien à voir ça je vous ai
dit que les meilleurs les attaques plus
dures à droite dans l'histoire les
pirates et analystes ont eu des diplômes
ça veut rien dire c'est jean meciar le
diplôme n'est pas vous mais le diplôme
ignore mais madame le 2e ligne le binôme
n'est pas un vaccin contre l'extrémisme
voilà et le t2 nous pensions le
diplomate
je vais vous dire les deux on ne vous
entend pas qu'aux par la nasa et le
nasdaq 1,21 contre l'islamisme madame
l'islamisme monsieur cessé de défendre
une femme c'est de défendre les femmes
qui préside une association pourrait
financer on est les frères musulmans
s'il vous plaît les enfants j'aimerais
qu'on dit j'aimerais coûté a causé par
madame je termine là dessus je parle
pour l'univers dc nos seniors à droite
je vais vous le dire je vais vous le
dire droit dans les yeux et je vais le
dire devant tous les téléspectateurs le
voile islamique n'a jamais fait partie
de l'identité nationale n'en fait pas
partie et n'en fera jamais vous
méconnaissez larmes c'est tout ce que ça
vous donne mon père fois la voilà mais
ça dit que le voile est resté dans les
cartons dans l'empiafée non madame ne va
pas chez les gens qui étaient de
nationalité française renseignez vous
allez vous parler de lui dira alors s'il
vous plaît répond j'aimerais j'aimerais
juste avoir le sentiment de de roland
lescure est ce que c'est un bad buzz
pour vous pour la république en marche
ou pas mais c'est à la fois une
clarification on clarifie les règles on
l'expriment
j'espère qu'on va on veut exclure
personne et je le répète le voile dans
la rue sur un plateau télévision ça ne
me dérange
en aucun cas mais quand on affiche une
couleur politique ont la fiche pour tout
le monde
son j'espère on arrive à clarifier tout
le monde qui est en train de montrer de
ce soir maskimo ce qui me frappe parce
que j'ai vécu dix ans au canada où ces
sujets sont discutées et parfois de
manière assez acrimonieux mais sans
violence on est capable
de partir au quart de tour sur ces
sujets là et je le regrette et on a
essayé de le faire ainsi fait rarement
on avait choisi moi je le regrette
ils ont une chair dans l'année qui
viennent on va pouvoir un débat y
compris sur ce plateau je serai prêt à
venir sur la laïcité sur ce que ça veut
dire à ce que ça ne veut pas dire et je
dois vous avouer que même au sein de
notre groupe
il ya au moins 50 nuage de la nation ans
de la licence vous pouvez faire une
réunion de groupe la ham et chelsea
aurait à peu près une douzaine d'âgés
différents jeux mais non parce que ce
débat là il est pas simple c'est une
erreur d'avoir d'abord demandé le
retrait et géraldine mais pour moi c'est
une erreur catastrophique moi je trouve
que c'est très bien que sarah travail
avec hélène avec mahfoud et avec régis
et voilà je trouve que finalement on
doit ces dames
soit tu enlèves tonton voile enfin en
fait on l'a bayonne on lui interdit de
s'engager on est interdit de s'émanciper
en fait on fait exactement ce qu'on
reproche parfois aux barbus et aux
islamistes radicaux à l'horizon vous
voyez ces femmes elles sont soumises à
elles peuvent pas s'engager elles
peuvent pas prendre la parole
donc voilà donc c'est une catastrophe
c'est contre-productif a permis côtier
pas du tout d'accord avec vous non je
suis pas d'accord et vous mes mails
autre chose que je ne comprends pas
c'est que ce sont quand même des
éléments de communication comment vous
pouvez vous retrouver dépassées par une
affiche très gros coup c'est quand même
pas exagérer il sait gérer 2015 donc oui
excusez moi donc
elle n'avait pas été encore publié je
pense que vous l'avez mise sur votre
page facebook
ça n'est donc c'est un député qui nous a
versé irani je trouve que ce n'est pas
ma millions de la république
mia dont on en a parlé avec vous et je
conçois les deux députés qui se tient je
consommais du bois mais avec une je
conçois que vous n'ayez pas rendre la
règle qui avait été discutée en bureau
exécutif ya 18 mois
donc c'est pour ça qu'on prend contact
avec vous en disant désolé on a une
règle
on en a discuté pendant des heures à peu
près dans ces termes là il ya 18 mois en
bureau exécutif
on se met d'accord sur une règle vous ne
la connaissez pas on vous la donne jules
4 x 5 x un moment de fête j'aimerais
vous donner la lettre pour vous envoyer
hélène sarah aujourd'hui elle est
découpée pourquoi il n'est pas venu
alors j'espère pas compris ce qu'est ce
qu'elle n'est pas venue aujourd'hui
parce que justement elle n'est pas un
porte étendard de quoi que ce soit nous
a dit qu'elle va peut-être venir demain
c'est savoir est ce que la bosse était
elle aussi de problèmes
ce type de décision c'est pas le porte
et a marre de quelque chose ça c'est une
citoyenne intégrés dans la vie à
montpellier qui travaillent qui activent
dans les associations qui aident les
jeunes dans leurs études
donc c'est elle de faire ses choix mais
surtout pas de porter quelque chose
qu'elle n'a plus à porter nadia vous
êtes déçu oui déçu parce qu'en fait je
pense que ce qu'on reproche à sarah
finalement c'est qu'elle est l'antithèse
de tout ce qui se dit depuis des
décennies sur les femmes qui arbore le
foulard on a une femme française qui
visiblement a fait un parcours
universitaire ou dans une grande école à
ses brillants elle est souriante elle
prend part à la vie dans la cité
certains arborent un foulard mais ça ne
elle n'est pas réduite à ce foulard est
donc finalement ça lui va bien rendre
inopérant en fait complètement tous vos
discours cet imaginaire tous ces
préjugés autour de la femme qui porte le
foulard est en fait sarah et comme la
plupart des femmes qui vous mettez vos
serments dérange ou maison où mes désirs
la limite parce que si vous voulez ou
nas et fuller qui en font leur
apparition sur des affiches électorales
on les voyait pas il ya encore dix ans
au on a les burnes l ailier pia pour les
alors à la raison de l'addition
on a même des grands concerts on arrache
et grandes enseignes
nadia l'on voit c'est nike et ses rivaux
samyn le tchèque assure est proposé
c'est d'avoir un djihadiste d'avoir un
taliban sur la fiche du doigt la
prochaine
ces eaux connues notamment mais j'ai une
question pour jour mais ça j'ai une
question pour monsieur quelqu'un
quelqu'un de peu de gens mais cela
prouve que l'association que sarah est
financé par les frères musulmans
sinon c'est de la diffamation vous avez
des articles je voulais des artistes
aussi qu'ils disent plein de bêtises
zarti pas trop loin non pas si je relève
relégué sortie qui est officiel je
voudrais le bal des séries mena bassam
et pauvres les gens peuvent vérifier
oui je le verrai vous dirai pas ce que
tu en avais une magnifique on avait une
magnifique affiche qui intégrait et jean
messia exclu avec ça moi je suis très
triste ce soir vraiment apprécié c'est
terrible voilà qui s'excluent elle-même
gildas s'en tirer en france et qu'on
veut s'intégrer on s'excluent pas
soi-même t pour la foulée apprendra le
mot de la fin de monsieur les toiles à
l'association de sarah allez allez allez
membres l'association ce sont des sons
des bénévoles dont ils sont hébergés à
la carte de la paix de la ou les
présidents macro et partiale et un
enfant qui il est hébergé là-bas par
l'état donc s'était fixée par beauvau
schisme l'activité de l'association
c'est quoi moi je travaille à côté et je
la connais les membres sont des
bénévoles qui font médecine format droit
ingénieurs et qui donne du soutien
scolaire pour des gamins du quartier et
que leur disent nous on n'a réussi à
c'est exactement ça elle fait ça pendant
cinq ans elle le fait est actuellement
elle travaille dans un laboratoire qui a
une mission aux missions pour faisaient
jusque là elle dit monsieur lescure
lescure qui est responsable de la
communication de la république comme à
roland lescure
qu'est ce qu'ils savaient de quoi la
suite pour sur la communication sur
cette affaire on en parle plus on passe
à autre chose mais j'espère qu'on va
passer à autre chose en en tirant
l'élection collective sur ce qui est dit
n'importe quoi quand même beaucoup à ma
gauche mais sur ce qui doit être
affirmée secular été plus habile
si on m'avait division média sera ma
gauche un jour moi je crois à ma droite
mais aussi surfer
non mais moi j'ai voté contre
l'interdiction du voile pour les petites
filles qui a été défendue à l'assemblée
et votre édition d'arras 14 jan missia
regardez monsieur dire oui à 36% non 64%
voilà le sondage de ce nom
m